Wednesday morning rainy London seems
appropriate
[Music]
just had a great breakfast with Eric low
water who runs a London vaynermedia that
was his back it's good to see you dear
och we haven't been travelling together
that much it's all going well blog just
kind of trucking along I think I think
hello Wow
how are you nice to meet you yeah real
quick real quick sorry I have an office
here okay and we're just going to a
meeting
don't worry don't worry Doreen we're not
gonna I'm not gonna let it uh let's just
means it's a great walk no oh my god a
big thanks awesome
so just a funny segue based off we're
just what just happened but so
interesting to me that like 96% of my
time is being the CEO and chairman of
Boehner X and the CEO vaynermedia we're
gonna happen actually this is a
challenge I'm putting to us we need to
do a lot work
why don't we do a vlog of like b-roll
because we can't show anything a lot of
sensitive information why don't we do an
episode where we use the entire Monday
to Monday playlist but show every
meeting and maybe right at the bottom
the meet a little context of the meeting
like like a cow meat you know anyway
that's what's up vlog busiest [ __ ]
building a machine we have a new office
in London I'm excited about it what's
what's up hello I'm super fired up to be
in London right now
I've been told will debark is a girl
take a trip around the world
we switch things up which guys trips to
London recently which has been I think
beneficial for Eric and the team
typically what we did was we just flying
on like a late flight and we get in in
the morning they kind of beat up a
red-eye and then only get like a quarter
of the day and a full day and fly home
under strategy is kind of fly out in the
morning get in that you know 8 p.m.
local which is mid-afternoon back in the
u.s. do two hours of calls hit the sack
and then and then just rip through two
full days but also switching it up a
little bit trying to get them more into
the media here just kind of get
ingrained in the culture so today is
just great full day some of their busy
days in his official press and then
tomorrow kind of ramping it up a little
bit and we've got a front pod session
set up tomorrow afternoon with some
soccer place and football players we
have the 40 so a lot of Dana folks are
here then we'll be Nicholson we may see
Claude
it's all about it a swiss event and
night it's gonna be kind of fun because
the first two pop-ups in tehran
we're really like time constraint 90
minutes two hours we had to just ripped
through ripped rip through this one's
got a little more time and so you know
it's gonna was it a year ago that we did
the last Meetup two years ago which is
like a big moment I think for everyone
was like oh [ __ ]
and and so tomorrow night we're kind of
just leaving it open and hopefully just
get a lot of the public be able to come
through and touch the vibe and should be
good
the new office is super bad they have a
coffee machine but I went out and bought
coffee right cuz I like I'm a big coffee
shop guy - I've [ __ ] up
[Music]
sent them on the road to a meeting Eric
likes logistics so we're good to go
and Alex is texting me I have four I am
back in New York right now she's on her
game we're rocking and rolling
[Music]
amazing I'm fired up Rhys got me fired I
mean the sweatshirt it's like I mean I
can't eat then by the way for all of you
that don't know that's the logo I grew
up with oh yeah that's that's it well
there they have the old school one now
they there was an old school one they
switched to that in the early 80s yeah
late 1770s and it went back to the
originals but that's like my logo
that's my logo which is really crazy I
was just saying to Gary we've got like
six seven people upstairs who all my
boys and this guy changed their lives
and make them stop doing stuff like
vlogging super crazy I can't wait to see
him it's nice to come to London that
much yeah
the vibe and energy like is really like
do you know it means because we don't
get to see just one screen I get it
thank you I mean tomorrow night's gonna
be crazy how are you nice to meet you
pleasure
how are you good to see you pleasure how
are you pleasure
are you guys new yorks at 12 inches
right now I'm feeling good about myself
three tips to get happy stay happy and I
guess financially secure but that goes
into the happiness as well well I don't
know about that like I really think the
money and Happiness thing is a very big
confusion most of my richest friends are
miserable and some of my poorest friends
are super happy so but um so that's just
one point but let's break it down couple
things the biggest reason people are
unhappy right now is because they value
somebody else's opinion more than they
that is the number one blanket statement
that I've got for everybody you're your
mother's point of view on you
your wife's point of view on you you're
your boyfriend's point of view your
homies point of view like the reason I'm
super happy is nobody can tell me
nothing
my wife mom and daughter could walk into
my room right now tell me on a piece of
crap and I would be 100% on things that
is some gangster emotional structure and
that's why I can never use I Know Who I
am and I just am unfazed so if my mom
daughter and wife could come in and tell
me I'm a piece of crap and I'm cool
what do you think that troll on
Instagram that says I suck does nothing
so you need to figure out the following
it is very likely that either your mom
or dad screwed you up they made you
insecure they didn't love you enough
they told you they you aren't good
because they weren't good and misery
loves company once you face that demon
once you cut out negativity and the
people that hold you down and you
surround yourself with positivity and
don't confuse delusion don't watch my
videos and rah rah up and you don't put
any work in nothing good is gonna happen
you're just gonna watch my videos so
don't get it confused but life is basic
you're either on the optimism team or
you're on the pessimism team your other
you're either on the offense or you're
on the defense the reason people are
unhappy is because let's talk about
money and unhappiness your three best
friends have a BMW and you don't you
think it's that you don't realize that I
loved when all my friends had BMWs and I
had nothing it's just perspective man
what are we doing here it's like what
are you valuing like what was
everybody's on defense all the
immigration issues in the world nobody's
taking yours do you think some
immigrants taking your job you suck like
if you think that right do you think
somebody else is taking your spot this
is the world we live in the rich it like
you don't rich this world in the UK
market you live in the UK and you're
complaining get the hell out so so
that's practical you you have a family
member or a childhood
that put you in a mindset of defense and
listen I know I'm gonna get a lot of
hits on Twitter and Instagram about this
interview now when I Spit this because I
know a lot of people haven't heard of me
or to have context I mean let me just
say this the answer to everything is and
what now right like I know people grew
up in alcoholic households I know people
were molested I know people had somebody
steal all their money here's my problem
nobody cares like what are you waiting
for
like like nobody's there is no fair
fairy flying down from the earth and
saying you were born an African American
in America where that's an issue here's
a million dollar it's not happening so
my thing is instead of dwelling and
wishing how it was understand back to
the next practical part of your question
that the Internet is now here and guess
what the Internet's not a 76 year old
white man it's the Internet and that
means everybody's got a shot so go take
yours it's happening on YouTube Facebook
Instagram go figure it out instead of
[ __ ] on it and thinking it sucks and
go get your money happiness and that's
it simple as that I got no time for
people complaining because it's just not
clean anymore
1986 yes 2018 what do you think's going
why do you think me toos happening now
the Internet one it's over go get yours
doing a pop-up store for the a swish
joints tomorrow so give me a lot of
people god I love this song when it came
out
timing is everything stay well take care
we haven't missed any so what do we have
one-on-ones all handsewn what that's
like it's my own Instagram account hey
everybody it's pro tip Tuesday we are at
the Red Rooster restaurant and shortage
here in London and we're about to
kick-off a roundtable dinner with a
bunch of really great people just
waiting for Gary to show up but once it
gets here this thing is gonna get going
a lot of good conversation hopefully
some debate but it's gonna be exciting
and some really good food I saw chicken
and waffles on the menu so let's get
going my favorite thing in like maybe
the world is getting together with smart
or interesting people and being involved
in one singular conversation so the what
we're gonna we're gonna have a little
more time to Yap a little bit but at
some point maybe in like 20 minutes
after we like order we're gonna go into
one conversation as a group you know I
think you positioned it with like the
voice and other things but obviously
with you here but like and obviously
that will come up but what I think we
should definitely talk about I'm just
gonna level it up a hair more which is
like culture attention current this
moment I'm obviously everybody will have
different perspectives but having this
group should be a lot of fun thank you
so much for everybody who was able to
make it thanks to the Vayner team that
slept over from new york to be a part of
this so why don't we do this why don't
we start with introductions to give
everybody context so who you are where
you work and maybe one little piece of
context about your career your points of
view so what I'm saying yes
[Music]
[Music]
you